-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-And finally, New Rule.
For all the progressives
and academics
who refer to Israel
as an outpost
of Western civilization
like it's a bad thing,
please note,
Western civilization
is what gave the world
pretty much
every goddamn liberal precept
that liberals
are supposed to adore.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
Individual liberty,
scientific inquiry, rule of law,
religious freedom,
women's rights, human rights,
democracy, trial by jury,
freedom of speech.
Please, somebody stop us
before we enlighten again.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
And since one can find
all these concepts
in today's Israel
and virtually nowhere else
in the Middle East, if anything,
the world would be
a better place
if it had more Israels.
Of course, this message falls
on deaf ears to the current crop
who reduce everything
to being only victims
or victimizers,
so Israel is lumped in
as the toxic fruit
of the victimizing West.
The irony being that
all marginalized people
live better today
because of Western ideals,
not in spite of them.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-Ma--
Martin Luther King used
Henry David Thoreau's essay,
Civil Disobedience,
to help shape
the civil rights movement.
The UN's Universal Declaration
of Human Rights owes its core
to Rousseau and Voltaire.
Cleisthenes never showed up
for a sexual harassment seminar.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
But without him,
there's no democracy.
The cop who murdered
George Floyd got 21 years
for violating
his Fourth Amendment rights,
an idea we got
directly from John Locke,
who no one in college
would ever study anymore
because he's so old,
and so White, and so dead.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
So Western.
Yes, that's how simple
the woke are,
it's never about ideas.
If it was,
would they be cheering on Hamas
for their liberation?
Liberation? To do what?
More freely preside
over a country
where there are no laws
against sexual harassment,
spousal rape, domestic violence,
homophobia, honor killings,
or child marriage.
This is who liberals think
you should stand with?
(SCOFFS) Women there
should be so lucky
as to get colonized
by anybody else.
And for the record,
the Jews didn't colonize Israel
or anywhere ever,
-except maybe Boca Raton.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Gaza wasn't seized by Israel,
like India or Kenya was
by the British Empire,
and the partitioning
of the region
wasn't decided by Jews,
but by a vote
of the United Nations in 1947,
with everyone from Russia
to Haiti voting for it.
But apparently,
they don't teach this
at Drag Queen Story Hour
anymore.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Now...
it is true that for too long,
we didn't study enough Asian,
or African,
or Latin American history.
But part of the reason
for that is, frankly,
there's not as much to study.
Colleges replaced courses
in Western Civ-- Boo!
Eyeroll, dead White men,
am I right?
They replaced that
with world civilization classes,
which is fine in theory,
but what it meant
in practice is,
you read queer poetry
of the African diaspora
instead of Shakespeare.
And I'm sure
there's value in both.
But as usual,
America only ever overcorrects,
and so we're at this place now
where the words "Western Civ"
became kind of a shorthand
for "White people
ruined everything."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-But... (CLEARS THROAT)
But they didn't ruin everything.
No, they didn't live up
to their own ideals
for far too long
and committed atrocities,
but people back then
were all atrocious,
not just the White ones,
depending on who had the power.
But it was
the Western Enlightenment
that gave rise to the notion
that the law of the jungle
should be curbed.
Henry David Thoreau,
John Stuart Mill,
Ralph Waldo Emerson,
Jean-Jacques Rousseau.
Three-named dudes.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
It was all about
three-named dudes.
Three-named dudes like that
were the OG
social justice warriors.
The ideas that came through
Athens, Rome, London, Paris,
and yes, Philadelphia,
are what make life good
for most people
in free societies today.
That the individuals have value,
and even the powers that be
must submit to the rule of law.
That punishment
should not be cruel and unusual.
The accused get pe--
People get a trial.
That there is such a thing
as a war crime.
Why is it that
every other culture gets a pass,
but the West is exclusively
the sum of the worst things
it's ever done?
You think only White people
colonized? (CHUCKLES)
Historians estimate
that the very non-Western
-Mr. Genghis Khan...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...killed 40 million people
and that was
in the 13th century.
He single-handedly
may have reduced
the world's population
by 11 percent.
On the other hand...
he kind of made up for it
because he was such a prolific
colonizer of vaginas...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...that today an estimated
16 million people
-are his direct descendants.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
So, stop saying
"Western civilization"
like it's a contradiction
in terms. It's not.
You're thinking
of moderate Republican.